is the greatest chess player who ever  lived I've been studying his games and  reading a lot about this place and he's  just an incredible person I think he's a  genius  when he was seven years old and they're  made with him all throughout his life I  think he would have been good at any  other  kid he's very far ahead of his time if  you were alive today he would still be  probably number two or number three in  the world  so that's good  very similar to uh  computer  yeah just the way the tea crushed  through the field winning eleventh year  on U.S Championship  winning fig fear against Diamond of six  here against Ben Larson I mean who beats  Ben Larson also at some point he had  like 25 26 no 20 28 pounds like 25  consecutive wins just really insane and  be familiar that his career was cut  short  but he's an incredible person